kimbap kimbap kimbap bah
that's not sushi but is it sushi this is
Korean sushi I believe I don't eat side
transiently
that's I see crab is that beef or spam
or what is going on in this 1 2 3
I'm good that was a good time what's
going on over time small mouth it's just
the whole thing is heaven wrapped in a
little roll mmm it's got some cooked
food in there with a little bit of
spices is this a fruit they're just
really crunchy aspect to it
ah oh that sound this is some tasty Bop
right over here
those look like sausages that have been
basting in kimchi for days
your Korean pasta right it tastes like
pasta I've actually made this before
this dish cake this is Duke I'm knowing
me I'm a little Korean expert it's very
good it's exceptionally chewy it's rice
compacted into this weird space sausage
is there anything inside there's nothing
inside
all right the spice is telling you to
stop but your tongue is telling you to
keep it cold what these are cookies whoa
oh wait that's a little things for us is
it an empanada or a pie oh it smells
like a gingerbread house Wow very bready
it's not sweet the craftsmanship on this
your Sanj I've been to space you can
probably make it like other things too
you can make like a little cat like
imagine like baymax like this being the
low B max no he spread bean is just like
pure angel
honestly I'm over the bread I just love
the red meat I'll never be over the
bread look at these new baby boys okay I
keep changing what I think it is I
thought it was like a grain burrito is
this meat it looks like a mix between
like blood sausage and rice this kind of
looks like a little sausage
oh is this blood thousand
very cool day I always enjoy a little
bit of salt with my blood I got too much
salt
I ruined what would've been her
otherwise pretty good food I didn't
remember eating play-doh as a child
until this moment and I'm like God I've
been here before
what can't say I like it he's still
chewing it he put it in his mouth five
minutes ago it's comforting in a sense
because I excuse me oh the blood birth
if you were to fight somebody's arm
that's what it tastes like uh yeah a
little bit
I would eat this again I feel like the
sushi is a solid appetizer Korean food
great Korean Street food eating major
everything almost everything was good
yeah certainly you're so you're so
focused on that on the guess yeah those
linger though though yeah they certainly
let her if this food is like pretty
inexpensive that's great because Steve
and I are cute dates right yeah yeah
we're keeps